[Música]
volvemos con nuestra sección de economía
en la que les traeremos las cifras que
esperábamos Pero antes hagamos un repaso
de un tema Juan Pablo lucupli y es el
informe del crecimiento económico
Mundial de la ONU que previsiones tiene
muy bien Buenos días Pues vamos
directamente a las cifras porque la ONU
pronosticó antes del crecimiento global
del 3% para 2023 y ahora redujo esa
previsión hasta el 1,9% una tasa de
crecimiento más una de las más bajas en
los últimos 20 años y eso es lo que
revisaremos esto en cuanto a las
Naciones Unidas estaba antes la tasa en
3% y la redujo hasta el 1,9% y ha dicho
también que si la inflación el tema del
covid 19 y el tema también de la guerra
en Ucrania mejora el panorama para 2024
también puede ser mucho mejor si miramos
el Banco Mundial hizo una previsión
antes para 2023 del 3% y también la
redujo hasta el 1,7%
también hasta la mitad y el fondo
monetario internacional que muchas veces
hace préstamos a diferentes naciones de
una provisión del 2,7 Esta previsión es
mucho más alta que la del resto
precisamente porque fue en octubre pero
ya veremos Cómo serán los cambios más
adelante bueno y antes de hablar de esos
cambios el fondo monetario internacional
Pues bien descarta una recesión mundial
pero el crecimiento todavía sigue a la
baja Cuáles son las cifras al respecto y
el fondo monetario internacional
mostró también un mapa de diferentes
áreas de Cómo estaría el tema también
económico para 2023 en el caso por
ejemplo de Estados Unidos hizo una un
recorte desde 2021 en 2022 ese ese
porcentaje también bajó mucho más y para
2023 se redujo significativamente para
la eurozona por ejemplo del 5,2 de 2021
hasta el 0,5 2023 una previsión bastante
estricta bastante crítica para América
Latina y el Caribe también hay un
descenso desde 6,9 hasta el 1,7 de 2023
bueno y África medio oriente y Asia no
se quedan atrás también con unas
previsiones unos recortes básicamente
generales caídas en todas las regiones
del mundo Juan Pablo y ahora sí habíamos
prometido que traeríamos la cifra del
pib de Estados Unidos y que ya salió hoy
la tenemos aquí actualizada en nuestras
noticias Cuáles son los datos que se
conocieron Juan Pablo pues María Clara
Así es recién sale esta noticia el pib
de la primera Economía del mundo
Entonces creció un 2,9% anual en el
período de octubre a diciembre de 2023
cuando se esperaba un crecimiento mucho
mejor menor del
2,6%. estos datos afectarán directamente
las decisiones del Banco Central de
Estados Unidos de la reserva Federal que
se reunirán del tren del 31 de enero al
primero de febrero y cuáles son esos
datos oficiales de Corea del Sur pues al
país no le fue nada bien el crecimiento
económico se ralentizó a un 2,6% en 202
desde el 4,1% que había reportado el
país en 2021 una caída notable en el
producto interno bruto que fue causada
por una mayor debilidad de las
exportaciones y de la inversión
empresarial en medio de la
desaceleración económica global
cambiamos de noticia y de región porque
Argentina está promoviendo un mercado
cannábico Cuáles son las últimas
noticias que se conocen es algo que ya
se lanzó el gobierno de Alberto
Fernández dijo que impulsará políticas
públicas para el uso medicinal e
Industrial cannábico con la intención de
explotar la cadena productiva de
comercio en palabras del ministro de
economía argentino abro comillas poner
en marcha esta agencia que significa
Iniciar una nueva industria en la
Argentina que tiene 25.000 aplicaciones
distintas va a permitir agregar valor en
la cosmética en lo textil en el petróleo
y en un innumerable cantidad de sectores
económicos en la Argentina del mundo
cierra comillas Gracias Juan Pablo por
toda la información económica y me
disculpara mi error tranquila todo está
muy bien Luego lo vemos con más luego
volvemos